Und jetzt noch ein Tor! Bravo!
Ja!
(Frau) Man muss einfach viel planen,
sich viel überlegen.
Aber es ist mittlerweile mein Hobby
geworden - Zeitmanagement.
(Mann) Wenn er Solist werden will,
heisst das täglich
schuften, schuften, schuften.
Vollgas geben,
bis die Finger bluten.
* Energische klassische Musik *
Hopp, Lena! Hopp, hopp, hopp!
Manchmal ist es schon anstrengend
und belastend.
Aber es braucht manchmal Bitteres,
damit das Süsse noch süsser wird.
Was nehmen Eltern auf sich,
um ihren Kindern Träume zu erfüllen,
und worauf müssen sie
deshalb verzichten?
Das Wohnzimmer der Familie Rosamilia
im aargauischen Hunzenschwil.
Die vier Kinder trainieren
für den nächsten Wettkampf.
Adriano,
Tiziana,
Nina
und die älteste Tochter Valentina.
Alle sind sportverrückt.
3 Std. Training pro Tag
sind keine Seltenheit.
Vater Gerardo
kümmert sich um die Ausrüstung.
Ordnung ist wichtig.
Mit vier Kindern ist die Logistik
nicht so einfach - v.a. mit Kindern.
Denn sie werfen
die Sachen jeweils hin.
Wenn ich von der Arbeit komme,
schaue ich erst mal,
ob alles da ist -
auch wenn kein Rennen ansteht.
Wenn etwas rumliegt, gehe ich hoch
und sage als Allererstes:
"Hoi, wie geht's? Kannst du bitte
deine Sachen wegräumen."
Denn wenn jemand etwas nicht findet,
beginnen die Konflikte.
Das Konfliktpotenzial ist relativ
gross - v.a. kurz vor der Abfahrt.
Mit ein paar Velos im Keller
hat alles begonnen.
Inzwischen ist der Keller
ein Logistikzentrum.
Unter der Woche arbeitet Gerardo
als IT-Techniker im Tessin.
An den Wochenenden dreht sich alles
um die Wettkämpfe der Kinder.
Seine eigenen sportlichen Interessen
muss er zurückstellen.
Für die Teilnahme an einem Triathlon
ist die Vorbereitung
besonders aufwendig.
Die bis zu 8'000 Fr. teuren Velos
müssen jedes Mal sorgfältig überprüft
und neu eingestellt werden.
Letztes Wochenende
hatten wir ein Rennen in Cuneo.
Dieses Wochenende ist Wallisellen,
wo ganz andere Bestimmungen gelten.
Überprüfen muss man immer,
ob alles funktioniert,
ob die Schaltung richtig ist ...
... ob die Bremsen ...
ob ein Kabel nachlässt.
Es wäre schon tragisch, wenn
während des Rennens etwas passiert
und dein weinendes Kind
vor dir steht:
"Papi!"
"Das hielt nicht,
du hast nicht geschaut."
Deshalb ist es manchmal besser,
wenn es der Mechaniker macht,
dann ist er schuld.
Mutter Caroline kümmert sich
unter der Woche um die Kinder.
Auch in ihrem Alltag dreht sich alles
um Sport und die richtige Ernährung.
Immer - beim Frühstück,
Mittag- und Abendessen -
sind Kohlenhydrate dabei.
Und nach dem Training
gibt's mehr Eiweiss.
Und auch zwischendurch Eiweiss.
Darauf schaut man schon.
Jetzt gibt's Reis,
Fleisch und Gemüse zu Mittag.
Das Haus ist auch eine Velowerkstatt.
Für ein Sofa ist kein Platz.
Puh!
Wo kann ich es hinlegen?
Nina.
Könntest du in der Schule nicht
kleinere Dinge basteln? - Nein.
Konntest du die Grösse selbst
aussuchen oder war sie vorgegeben?
Selbst.
- Im Wohnzimmer ist kein Platz.
Doch, doch.
- Alles voller Velos.
Bring es in dein Zimmer!
- Das kann ich nachher tun.
Wenn dein Riesenkissen
hier unten sein soll,
müssen wir Platz machen,
die Medaillen hochräumen.
Du trägst es,
und ich nehme mit, was runterfällt.
* Klirren *
Über 600 Medaillen haben sich
die vier Nachwuchssportler
in den letzten Jahren erkämpft.
Du nimmst mit, was runterfällt.
- Ja.
Und jedes Wochenende
kommen neue dazu.
So.
Einfach draufwerfen.
Da sind noch welche.
Die bleiben jetzt aber hier.
Im Bad.
Habt ihr die Hände gewaschen?
- (Alle) Ja.
Die Blumen, die Valentina gewann,
halten lange. - Sehr.
Isst du auch mit?
- Nein, ich brauche keins.
Ich muss die Geige bereitmachen
für Raphael. Zum Geigenbauer.
Kannst du bitte helfen?
Ein gemeinsames Mittagessen daheim
ist bei Familie Nussbaumer selten.
Der Sohn muss sich oft auf der Fahrt
zum nächsten Termin verpflegen.
Er wünscht sich auch andere Sachen.
Manchmal sagt er, es sei langweilig.
"Schon wieder Sandwichs".
Donat und Puk Nussbaumer
wohnen mit ihren beiden Kindern
Seraina und Raphael in Altendorf/SZ.
Der 13-Jährige spielt Geige,
seit er vier Jahre alt ist.
Dreimal die Woche
fährt ihn der Vater nach der Schule
zum Musikunterricht nach Zürich.
Heute legen sie einen Zwischenstopp
beim Geigenbauer in Rapperswil ein.
Raphaels Geige muss justiert werden.
Salute!
- Hallo, Raphael.
Hallo, Michael.
- Hoi, Donat.
Geht's gut?
- Ja, danke.
Können wir sie kurz einstellen?
Sie ist etwas verstimmt.
Kannst du sie mal spielen, Raphael?
Dann hören wir das Problem.
* Virtuoses klassisches Spiel *
Ja.
- Sie klingt etwas dumpf.
- Klarer sein.
Mhm.
Das Talent
hat Raphael wohl vom Vater.
Donat Nussbaumer ist Berufsmusiker
und spielt ebenfalls Geige.
So, probier noch mal, Raphael.
* Gleiche Melodie
mit etwas hellerem Klang *
Besser - es ist kerniger.
- Besser, was?
Strahlt mehr raus, finde ich.
- Ja.
Ich denke ...
- Was meinst du? Lassen wir es so?
Sie hat noch das Kräftige drin,
aber man kann leise spielen.
Trotzdem kommt sie
gegen das Orchester durch.
Gut.
Raphael darf probeweise auf
der fast 300-jährigen Geige spielen.
Die Suche nach dem richtigen
Instrument ist aufwendig
und geht ins Geld.
Mit einem Instrument
für - sagen wir mal - 5'000 Fr.
wird er nach kürzester Zeit
unglücklich,
weil es seine Ansprüche
nicht erfüllt.
Es gibt nichts Schlimmeres,
als wenn er in seiner Entwicklung
durchs Instrument gebremst wird,
weil es dieses
einfach nicht hergibt.
Es ist eine alte Geige.
Man weiss nicht, wer sie gebaut hat.
Wenn man das weiss, kann es schnell
einige Hunderttausend kosten.
Bei dieser, ja.
Es ist die Geige,
die ich in Zukunft spielen möchte.
Okay, dann. Tschüss, Michael, danke.
- Tschau, Donat.
Tschau, Raphael, mach's gut.
- Tschüss.
Es wäre seine Wunschgeige.
Ob er sie auch
weiterhin spielen darf,
werden seine Eltern
in den nächsten Monaten entscheiden.
So, genau. Achtung!
Die Familie Bosanac wohnt
mit ihren drei Kindern in Zürich.
Ein paar Hundert Meter von
der Kunsteisbahn Oerlikon entfernt.
Mutter Marija bringt ihre Buben zwei-
mal die Woche ins Eishockeytraining.
Vater Mladen kommt von der Arbeit.
Der Sachbearbeiter verbringt
fast jeden Abend auf der Eisbahn.
Tochter Julia
kommt etwas später dazu.
Bist du müde?
- Freitag.
Julia kommt auch.
- Ich habe sie gesehen.
20 Min. braucht der siebenjährige
Nikola, um die Ausrüstung anzuziehen.
Vom Klub bestimmte Eltern
helfen den Kindern.
Andere Erwachsene werden in
den Umkleidekabinen nicht geduldet.
Nikola trainiert seit zwei Jahren
beim Zürcher Schlittschuhclub.
Komm, Junge. Das machst du!
- Und jetzt dribbeln!
Jetzt Slalom. Pylonen dribbeln,
Trainer dribbeln, alles dribbeln.
Er hat es nicht verlernt.
Komm! Gas, Gas, Gas!
Jetzt ist er in seinem Element.
Jetzt kommt er und ... Bravo! Fast.
(Petar) Verkackt.
- Ei, ei, ei.
Freitag ist schön, weil
alle drei Kinder Training haben.
So können wir die Zeit
als Familie etwas geniessen.
Petar wartet jetzt mit uns -
wir können noch etwas besprechen
und schauen Nikola zu.
Dann ist Nikola fertig
und Petar auf dem Eis.
Dann schaut er dem Bruder zu,
und Julia kommt auch.
Sie hat auch Training.
Die KEBO ist wie
unser zweites Zuhause, mittlerweile.
Oder das erste.
- Ja, oder das erste.
Wir verbringen hier viel Zeit.
Nikola und Petar
haben je zwei Trainings, also vier.
Das sind mind. 6-8 Std.
Manchmal bin ich hier,
wenn Julia trainiert -
ich will auch sie sehen,
nicht nur Hockeyaner.
Das sind noch zusätzliche Stunden.
Also 9-10 Std. pro Woche Training.
Dazu kommen Turniere
am Wochenende, ganz- oder halbtags.
Und Mama kommt auch gern, wenn sie
keine anderen Verpflichtungen hat.
Sie hat ziemlich viel um die Ohren.
Ja, ich muss nicht erklären, was.
Das ist klar mit drei Kindern.
Neben dem Haushalt
arbeitet Marija als Übersetzerin
und in der Kulturvermittlung.
Sie engagiert sich
auch in der Schulpflege
und koordiniert die Termine
der drei Kinder.
Meist am Sonntag oder Montagmorgen
mache ich jede Woche
einen Plan für die gesamte Woche.
Am Montag
haben beide Jungs Training,
einfach an verschiedenen Orten.
Das müssen wir als Eltern aufteilen.
Julia hat einen ganzen Nachmittag
Training.
Aber sie geht
direkt von der Schule hin.
Ich bringe ihr die Trainingssachen
und etwas Kleines zu essen
nach der Schule.
D.h., diese Woche
wird ziemlich aktiv.
Sie ist immer im Stress.
Nikola erwartet sie,
Julia steht bereits auf dem Eis,
und das Training des neunjährigen
Petar ist in vollem Gange.
Ich geniesse es einfach.
Ich mache das immer gern. Ohne Witz.
Ohne überheblich zu sein
oder etwas Spezielles zu sagen.
Es ist wirklich so.
Auch wenn du unangemeldet kommst,
siehst du mich hier.
Denn es ist halt jetzt mein Leben.
Bei Julias Training zuzuschauen, ist
für mich Freizeit und Entspannung.
Ich kann sitzen
und muss nichts machen.
Das nutze ich schon viel,
wenn es zeitlich aufgeht.
Die ersten Schlittschuhe
hatte Julia mit vier -
jetzt ist sie zwölf und steht
pro Woche bis zu 9 Std. auf dem Eis -
Sommer und Winter.
Nur mit eiserner Disziplin
kann man beim anspruchsvollen
Training mithalten.
Karriere
ist mir persönlich völlig wurst.
Natürlich wünsche ich mir, dass
seine Träume in Erfüllung gehen -
NHL oder so.
Aber ich bin nicht so,
dass ich ihn dazu drängen würde.
Im Stil: "Du musst alles aufgeben!"
Das würde ich nie machen.
Denn ich weiss aus meinem Umfeld,
dass das nicht unbedingt gut ist.
Denn irgendwann kommt es: Das Kind
hat keine Chance oder keine Lust.
Meiner Meinung nach
ist das nicht gut.
Er muss selber gehen und wenn es
ihm wirklich so gut läuft ...
Dann soll er dabei bleiben.
Der Sport der Kinder
ist für die Familie
eine finanzielle Herausforderung.
Eiskunstlauf kostet schnell
rund 20'000 Fr. pro Jahr.
Die Wettkämpfe
werden separat berechnet,
und man muss für sie einzahlen.
Dazu kommt die Ausrüstung,
die Julia braucht.
Schlittschuhe sind ab einem gewissen
Niveau ziemlich teuer -
bis zu 1'000 Fr.
Hoi, Mami.
Die Jungs brauchen die Sachen
halt oft, die sie anziehen.
Und sie wachsen auch.
Es ist auch so,
dass man fast jede Saison
eine komplett neue Ausrüstung
braucht.
Der Preis für eine neue Ausrüstung
beträgt um die 1'500 Fr.
Damit kannst du alles trocknen.
Unten ist ein Gebläse - hier.
Du riechst fast nichts.
Wenn sie natürlich
auf gewöhnlichem Weg trocknen,
stinkt es mehr.
Warum, weiss ich auch nicht.
Bist du auch langsam fertig, Papa?
- Komme gleich.
So, bist du fertig?
- Ja. Guten Appetit.
Super, guten Appetit.
- Jetzt sind wir fertig.
Okay, also. Super.
Die erfolgsverwöhnte Valentina
muss mit 16 Jahren entscheiden,
in welche Richtung
ihre sportliche Karriere geht.
Ihre Eltern reden und planen mit.
Sie haben schon grossen Einfluss.
Sie sind ja meine Eltern
und unterstützen mich.
Ohne ihre Hilfe
würde ich es auch nicht schaffen.
Sie unterstützen mich finanziell
und mental.
Ja, also ... Sie sind schon wichtig.
Die Eltern besprechen
die Planung der Wettkämpfe.
Wir haben einen Doodle.
Worauf drücke ich? "Woman".
Ja, "Wettkampfplan".
"Woman", natürlich.
Lässt du hier bitte offen?
- Ja.
Schauen wir uns den April an.
Hier haben wir Luzern. Was hier
steht, hast du gesehen, oder?
Adriano ...
- Nur noch Nina.
... Tiziana haben als letztjährige
Sieger einen Gutschein. - Genau.
Valentina hat eine persönliche
Einladung für das Eliterennen.
Dann müssen wir
nur noch Nina anmelden.
Aber das ist jetzt schon zu spät.
Schon 10 Fr. Zuschlag.
Während die Eltern
Termine jonglieren,
üben sich die Kinder
in autogenem Training.
(Frau)
Ich bin ganz ruhig und entspannt.
Mein Körper ist angenehm warm ...
... das Herz und die Atmung ruhig
und gleichmässig.
Der Bauch weit und frei ...
Weiter geht's. Hier haben wir
De Schnellscht Aarauer.
Am 18.
ist die grösste Herausforderung.
Da sind drei Dinge.
Und der ZKB geht halt nicht, oder?
Jetzt holst du dir
ein Bild vor dein inneres Auge,
als du als Sieger
auf dem Podest standest.
Altstadt wäre noch.
Das ist etwas spät, 14.30 Uhr.
Dann haben wir den hier in Zofingen.
Denn hier machen wir ja Yoga.
Und genau an diesem Sonntag
wäre der Uri-Triathlon.
Theoretisch könnten wir schon
am Freitag oder Samstag
vom Yoga heimfahren -
aber da fährst du 13 Std.
Nein, wir müssen nicht alles machen.
Schon, aber sie darf
nur ein oder zwei Rennen fehlen.
Die Bilder vor deinem inneren Auge
verschwinden langsam,
und du kommst wieder zurück
ins Hier und Jetzt.
Hattet ihr alle ein Bild?
- (Alle) Ja.
Natürlich.
Ich hatte ein Bild,
als ich fünf war.
Das ist schon länger her.
Cool, super.
Ich, als ich Vizemeister wurde.
- Sehr schön.
Wir schauen heute noch mal genau an:
Was machen wir 10 Min.
vor dem Start eines Wettkampfs?
Was macht ihr in diesem Moment?
Ich mache das autogene Training,
vor dem Start,
und gehe es noch mal im Kopf durch.
Ja, den Wettkampf
gehst du noch mal durch? - Ja.
Wunderbar, cool. Ihr macht das gut.
Ich mache
in diesen vier Tagen alles allein.
Dazu gebe ich Aerobic-Stunden
in der Migros-Klubschule in Aarau.
Ich nehme mir aber manchmal
auch Zeit nach dem Mittagessen,
wenn ich merke, dass ich müde bin.
Dann lege ich mich
eine halbe Stunde hin.
Einfach, um mich zu erholen.
Das habe ich gut im Griff.
Auch wenn ich Arbeit habe,
die ich dringend erledigen sollte.
Aber wenn ich mir die Zeit
zum Runterfahren nicht nehme,
tue ich niemandem einen Gefallen -
weder mir noch der Familie.
Da sind halt die Böden dreckig,
und ich lege mich kurz hin.
Danach sind die Böden
immer noch dreckig.
Seit Raphael fünf Jahre alt ist,
besucht er den Musikunterricht
im Musikkonservatorium in Zürich
beim Dirigenten und Violinpädagogen
Philip Draganov.
Eine Ausbildung,
in die seine Eltern viel investieren
und die von Raphael
sehr gewissenhaft verfolgt wird.
So, wie geht's dir?
- Gut.
Okay, gut. Lass uns stimmen!
* Langer, gleicher Ton *
* Sich daran anpassender
zweiter Ton *
* Dramatische, intensive Klänge *
* Schnelle, komplexe Melodie *
Okay, versuch, diese erste
lange Note wirklich zu entwickeln.
Jedes Detail der Beurteilung
im Unterricht wird vom Vater notiert.
* Einzelner Ton *
Ja? Und wie viele Schläge es ist.
Eins, zwei, weg.
Na?
* Gleiche Tonabfolge *
Schon besser, aber die zweite Note
ist zu schnell.
Jada ...
Und weniger stark und aggressiv.
Beim zweiten Mal
ist es schon viel mehr.
* Fröhliche Melodie *
Stolz!
* Philip Draganov
singt einige Sequenzen mit. *
Okay, wir müssen leider
zum Schluss kommen.
Aber es ist schon sehr gut
fürs erste Mal.
Nächstes Mal
arbeiten wir mehr in die Tiefe.
Es ist ein sehr langer Weg.
Geiger müssen früh anfangen,
mit vier oder fünf.
Es ist wichtig,
dass junge Menschen träumen dürfen.
Dafür stehe ich ein.
Sie sollen das Ziel haben, Solist
zu werden - das ist motivierend.
Aber man muss sich
auch bewusst sein,
dass weltweit nicht jedes Jahr
ein neuer Solist geboren wird.
Um eine sehr gute Orchesterstelle
zu bekommen ...
Da bewerben sich
auf eine offene Stelle 600 Personen
in einem guten Orchester
der Stadt Zürich -
und die kommen aus der ganzen Welt.
Da muss man
schon sehr, sehr gut sein.
Wie oft im Leben:
Man braucht das Quäntchen Glück,
um zur richtigen Zeit
am richtigen Ort zu sein,
um von der richtigen Person
gehört zu werden.
Es gibt viele Faktoren,
die reinspielen.
Ob sich das Engagement der Eltern
gelohnt hat, wird sich erst zeigen,
wenn Raphaels Ausbildung
abgeschlossen ist.
* Bewegte klassische Klänge *
Es ist 5 Uhr.
An diesem Samstag müssen
Vater und Sohn sehr früh aufstehen.
Petar spielt mit seiner Mannschaft
an einem Eishockeyturnier in Wil.
Auch die Mutter ist schon wach.
Sie begleitet heute den jüngeren Sohn
Nikola an ein Turnier in Küsnacht.
So sind die Eltern Bosanac an den
Wochenenden meist getrennt unterwegs.
Anziehen und raus?
Drei, zwei, eins - go!
Komm, Peki, hopp!
Je!
Aufteilen, aufteilen!
Bravo!
- Gut, 2:0.
Bravo, Peki!
Schön gemacht, 4:0!
* Pfiff *
Yes!
Hey, super.
Du warst super.
Wie viele Tore hast du geschossen?
- Eins.
Nur eins? Okay.
Ihr habt super gespielt.
15:1 war das Endergebnis.
Papi, hast du gesehen,
ich habe übers ganze Feld gespielt
und Tobi vors Tor.
- Ja. Ein Monsterpass.
Nicht nur von den Nachwuchsspielern
wird voller Einsatz erwartet,
auch die Arbeit des ehrenamtlichen
Trainers ist zeitintensiv.
Mind. dreimal pro Woche Training,
plus Match am Wochenende.
Der Aufwand ist relativ gross.
Viermal pro Woche
haben wir morgens Free Training,
das ist aber freiwillig.
Frühmorgens aufstehen, um 5 oder
4.30 Uhr - das macht nicht jeder.
Ein freier Tag pro Woche -
das ist das Maximum.
Ketchup und Senf?
Heute bin ich bestimmt 8-17 Uhr -
also 9 Std. - in der Halle.
Es ist nie warm oder angenehm -
es ist immer kalt.
In manchen Hallen kann man sich
nicht gut genug anziehen -
es ist sehr, sehr kalt.
Immerhin kann sich Vater Mladen heute
über den Turniersieg seines Sohnes
mit den ZSC-Binis freuen.
Hier um die Dinger rum, zurück,
die Treppe hoch und dann ...
Wir können das Velo hinstellen,
dann kannst du es üben.
Der Schwan ist auch dabei.
Valentina ist auf Erfolgskurs.
In der Leichtathletik
und im Triathlon
zählt sie beim Nachwuchs
zur Schweizer Spitze.
Mutter Caroline stoppt die Zeit.
Das mache ich
für den Triathlon morgen.
Morgen ist wohl Neoprenpflicht.
Da ist es gut, wenn man Anfang
Saison übt, den Neopren auszuziehen.
Denn es ist nicht einfach.
Bringt man ihn nicht ab,
verliert man Zeit.
Gerade nach dem Schwimmen
ist es wichtig,
in eine gute Velogruppe zu kommen,
um gut mitfahren zu können,
v.a. wenn Drafting erlaubt ist.
Es kann schon etwas ausmachen.
Die vierfache Mutter hat früher
ebenfalls Leichtathletik betrieben.
Sie ist die wichtigste Stütze
für Valentina
und ihre erste und wahrscheinlich
ehrlichste Kritikerin.
Gut, ich bin bereit.
Bisher haben wir den Sport
als Familie betrieben.
Wir haben die Anlässe so geplant,
dass wir immer als Familie
hingehen konnten.
Valentina
macht jetzt das Sportgymnasium.
Sie macht
jetzt wirklich Leistungssport.
Sie geht nicht mehr irgendwohin
und sieht ihre Freundinnen.
Sondern sie geht ins Training,
macht das sec durch
und kommt nach Hause lernen.
Sie hat wenige soziale Kontakte.
Das beschäftigt uns momentan.
Da entstehen auch Diskussionen
mit Caroline -
sie hat ihre Idee, ich auch.
Wir sind in einer kreativen Phase,
in der wir schauen müssen,
was für alle das Beste ist.
Die Familie werden wir mit ihr
sicher nicht mehr
so unter einen Hut bringen.
Aber damit müssen wir uns abfinden.
Das ist der Lauf der Zeit.
Das ist so.
Ah!
So.
Fertig.
Ich würde es noch mal machen.
- Ja.
* Rockmusik: "Boulevard
Of Broken Dreams" von Green Day *
Während Adriano
in der Musikecke Dampf ablässt,
sind seine Geschwister
mit den Gedanken
bereits beim nächsten Wettkampf.
Wenn man im Ziel ankommt und weiss,
dass man alles gegeben hat,
fühlt man sich besser,
als wenn man ankommt und denkt:
"Ich habe etwas
nicht so gut gemacht"
oder
"Irgendwie habe ich noch Kraft."
Das ist ein schlechteres Gefühl,
als wenn man alles gegeben hat.
Dieses Jahr
bin ich im älteren Jahrgang -
da sind sicher
auch einige Gute dabei.
Aber ja ...
Einfach das Beste draus machen.
Ich kann mich nie richtig erinnern,
aber ich glaube schon, dass ich
letztes Jahr gewonnen habe.
Morgen habe ich einen Triathlon.
Und ich versuche natürlich,
zu gewinnen.
Auch die zwölfjährige Julia
hofft auf Erfolg.
Für die Kür
an der Stadtmeisterschaft in Zürich
hat sie ein Jahr lang hart trainiert.
Die Konkurrenz ist gross.
Einfach wird es nicht.
Dass Julia siegen kann,
beweisen ihre Pokale und Medaillen.
Das ist aus Chur.
Das war letztes Jahr -
ich war auf dem zweiten Platz.
Ich hätte eigentlich
den ersten gewonnen,
aber da war noch
ein besseres Mädchen.
Das war dann etwas schade.
Aber es war trotzdem
einer meiner besten Wettkämpfe.
Heute ist wohl der Doppelaxel
das Schwierigste.
Den kann ich noch nicht so gut.
Aber ich hoffe,
dass er heute gut wird.
Auch Julias Ausrüstung geht ins Geld.
Sparen können sie,
weil die Mutter die Kleider
für den Auftritt selber näht.
Das sind alles Swarovski-Steine.
Bis zu 1'000 Steine hat ein Kleid.
Die haben schon einen schönen Preis.
Dieses hat um die 500 Steine.
Sicher, die Schiedsrichter
schauen auch auf das Aussehen.
Es gehört zur ganzen Performance.
Ich hoffe schon, dass sie
ihren Doppelaxel zeigen kann,
den sie sich vorgenommen hat.
Wenn alles klappt
und sie nicht stürzt,
sind wir schon zufrieden.
Denn es ist schon
ein spezieller Tag für sie.
Aber auch für mich als Mutter.
Denn ich muss ihre Freude oder
vielleicht weniger schönen Momente
auch miterleben
und sie unterstützen.
Und trösten, wenn es sein muss.
Raphael und seine Eltern
sind in Biel.
Am Abend wird der 13-Jährige
im Kongresshaus als Solist auftreten.
Er hat seine Wunschgeige dabei.
Heute wurde sie gekauft.
Jetzt gehört sie definitiv mir.
Und jetzt gleich
ein Konzert auf ihr spielen -
das macht schon elend Spass.
Den Kauf der 300-jährigen Geige
haben sich die Eltern lange
und gründlich überlegen müssen.
Sie ist
mehrere Zehntausend Franken wert.
Es ist ein grosser Aufwand.
V.a. weil ...
Im Vergleich: Die teuerste Aus-
bildung ist immer noch die zum Arzt.
Dann kommt schon der Musiker.
Die meisten denken: "Was, Musiker?
Man geht zur Hochschule und fertig."
Doch so ist es nicht.
Man beginnt schon als Kind,
zahlt die Schulgelder.
Dann ein Instrument -
je nach Alter ein neues.
Rechnet man alles zusammen,
ist es schon
eine sehr idealistische Rechnung.
Aber dann
wird man wieder entschädigt,
wenn man hört,
dass die Kinder Spass haben -
egal, wie viel es kostet.
Etwas Nervosität ist da.
Aber ... Das gehört dazu,
auch fürs Adrenalin.
Es ist immer wichtig,
dass die Eltern dabei sind.
Sie sind eine grosse Unterstützung.
Im Kongresshaus Biel
beginnen bald die Proben.
Raphael tritt als Solist
mit dem Sinfonie Orchester
Biel Solothurn auf.
Das Konzert wird
vom Schweizer Radio aufgezeichnet.
Du kannst mal losdudeln,
wenn du willst.
Wenn du fertig bist,
komme ich Tschüss sagen.
Einfach Musik machen, Spass haben.
Da ist auch Publikum?
- Ja, wohl nicht so viel.
Aber du musst aufpassen -
wenn der Saal voll ist,
ist einiges etwas trockener.
Aber jetzt hallt es.
- Ja, gell.
Da kommt der Dirigent.
Aber dich sieht man nicht.
Nein,
Englisch musst du mit ihm reden.
Oder Französisch.
Viel Spass.
* Orchester stimmt die Instrumente. *
Bonjour, Raphael.
Ca va? Bienvenu.
Je vous presente Raphael.
* Applaus *
* Ausschweifende, süsse Melodie *
So, also. Du hast die Räder
schon abgeschraubt? Vielen Dank.
Wunderbar.
Einmal mehr: Abfahrt zum Wettkampf.
Heute starten drei der vier Kinder
am Triathlon in Wallisellen.
Für den Nachmittag
sind nass-kühle 8 °C vorhergesagt.
Die Rosamilias sind dafür gerüstet.
Jetzt geht's los, was?
Nina, hast du deine Nudeln dabei?
- Ja.
Die beiden Kleinen können wir noch
managen, ihnen Anweisungen geben.
Bei Nina wird es schon schwieriger.
Sie ist in einem Alter,
in dem sie alles besser weiss.
Wenn sie Rat braucht,
kommt sie schon.
Aber momentan konzentrieren wir uns
auf die Kleinen.
Trinkt bitte etwas Wasser.
Nina sagte gerade, wir nerven sie,
wenn wir hier stehen.
Früher suchte sie uns immer:
"Wo seid ihr? Was macht ihr?"
"Ihr seid nicht da!"
Jetzt merken wir,
dass wir überflüssig werden.
Tizi! Lächeln!
Trink immer zwischendurch, gell.
Und geh vorher zur Toilette!
Adriano, trockne dich dann gut ab!
Und zieh die Mütze an!
Nicht mit nassen Haaren
auf die Strasse.
Bist du im kleinsten Gang, Adriano?
- Ja!
Gut.
Tiziana, seid ihr im kleinsten Gang?
- Was?
Seid ihr im kleinsten Gang?
- Ja!
* Stimmengewirr *
Wo sind sie?
Sind sie schon gestartet? - Ja.
Ich komme.
Schnell!
(Speaker)
... einen schönen Schwimmstil ...
Oh, jetzt ist eine vor ihr,
die Frosch schwimmt.
Jetzt muss sie die überholen.
Bravo, Tiziana, bravo!
- Hopp, Tizi!
In der Wechselzone, gut?
Hopp, hopp!
Bravo! Komm! Los! Hopp, hopp, hopp!
Super.
Super! Ist es gut gegangen?
- Gut.
Schön ruhig runterfahren.
Super gemacht.
Ich gehe zu Adriano, gell?
Du kannst die Kleider unten holen.
Tschüss, bis nachher!
(Keuchend) Ich habe ihn verpasst.
Schon durch.
Wo bist du?
Ja, die habe ich gesehen.
Sie ist im Ziel.
Ist Adriano
schon beim Wechsel durch?
Weisst du das?
Noch nicht. Dann gehe ich
zum Wechsel. Okay, tschüss.
Schau, jetzt sehen wir sie noch mal.
Endspurt, komm! Endspurt, Endspurt!
Hopp, hopp, hopp!
(Speaker) 100 m sind sie geschwommen,
5 km auf dem Velo
und 1 km sind sie gerannt.
Wie ging's?
Super.
Hey!
- Ich bin Erste.
Nein? Woher weisst du das?
- Ja.
Bei my.raceresult siehst du es.
- Und du?
Wissen wir noch nicht.
- Robin habe ich geschlagen.
Ging's mit dem Bauch?
- Ja.
Und war dir kalt?
- Nein.
Du bist ab wie eine Rakete.
Tiziana hat schon mal gewonnen.
Sie war nicht schlecht.
Sie hat beim Laufen aufgeholt.
Da ist sie 4,08.
Bei Adriano
ist noch nichts draussen.
Gemäss dieser Liste ist er Zweiter,
bisher.
Jetzt warten wir halt.
Gleich kommt Nina wieder.
Da kommt sie! Bravo! Endspurt!
Hm?
- Ich glaube, ihr ist kalt.
Hier. Sie ist ...
... Erste.
Und die Zweite ...
... hatte fast 1 1/2 Min. länger
auf dem Velo.
Entschuldigung, darf ich kurz durch?
- Im Schuss?
Ja!
Nina, bravo!
Gut! Du bist schön gerannt.
Super!
- Super, gut gemacht.
Du warst super.
- Schön, ja.
Ging's gut?
- Ich habe mich langsam gefühlt.
Nein, du warst schnell.
Die schnellste Velozeit.
Jetzt musst du dich anziehen.
- Nein, mir ist heiss.
Sonst bist du erkältet im Lager.
Willst du meine Jacke?
(Speaker) Man darf die tiefen
Temperaturen nicht unterschätzen.
Genau, mach die Jacke zu!
Sieht auch aus - hast du gehört?
Tja.
Cool. Jetzt können wir entspannen.
- Genau.
Morgen mache ich nichts.
Oder ist morgen etwas?
Die Kinder zum Bahnhof bringen.
- Genau, sie verreisen.
Morgen gehen alle ins Lager.
Abends sind wir allein.
Nina geht am Morgen
nach Wallisellen.
Aber morgen sind wir allein?
- Ja. Was machen wir?
Ich weiss nicht.
- Essen gehen.
Hopp, Alischa! Hopp, hopp, hopp!
Für Julia und ihre Mutter
ist die Eishalle Oerlikon
wie ein zweites Zuhause.
Für Julia gilt's ernst.
An der Stadtmeisterschaft
treten die drei Eiskunstlaufklubs
aus Zürich gegeneinander an.
Vor dem Auftritt
muss Julia die eigens für die Kür
zusammengestellte Musik abgegeben.
Mini?
- Ja.
Viel Glück.
- Danke.
So. Julia!
- Juki!
Viel Glück.
Toi, toi, toi.
- Du schaffst das. Gut?
(Speakerin) Wir fahren fort
mit dem Einlaufen
der Kategorie SEV Mini Damen.
Eine letzte Aufwärmrunde
vor dem grossen Auftritt.
Julias Brüder
fiebern so oft wie möglich mit.
Andere Familien
versammeln sich im Wohnzimmer,
Familie Bosanac
trifft sich in der Eishalle.
Du schaffst das.
- Hopp, hopp, hopp. Jetzt!
Ah, sch... Jetzt ist sie nervös.
(Speakerin) Als nächste Läuferin
sehen wir auf dem Eis:
Julia Bosanac
vom Eissport Club Zürich-Oerlikon.
Jetzt kommt unsere Julia.
Jetzt mitfiebern!
Jetzt. Jetzt gilt es ernst.
Jetzt gilt es ganz ernst.
* Dramatische klassische Klänge *
Komm jetzt! Du schaffst das.
Ja, das ging gut.
- Super. Nicht gut, super!
Super.
Komm, Juki!
* Schlussklang *
Yes!
- Super.
Jetzt kannst du werfen.
- Werfen, werfen!
Bist du zufrieden?
- Ja.
Ja!
Super. Yes!
Am Anfang ist sie
zwei-, dreimal umgefallen.
Sie versuchte den Zweifachen -
oder wie das heisst.
Da muss man mitfiebern.
Mein Daumen ist fast verdrückt.
Es lief super.
Der Trainer ist zufrieden,
sie auch -
dann bin ich als Laie begeistert.
Ich sehe, dass sie strahlt.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Dass sie Ende Wettkampf
glücklich ist und Freude hat.
Je, je, je, je!
Super, was?
Bravo, super. Kleiner Engel.
In Biel muss Raphael
in einer halben Stunde auf die Bühne.
* Kakophonie
von sich aufwärmenden Musikern *
Alles gut?
Bis dann. Viel Spass!
- Ja.
Einfach toll spielen, gell.
Viel Glück - und strahle!
Mach's gut!
- Mhm.
Wie immer.
Bis später auf der Bühne.
Jetzt ist der 13-Jährige
ganz auf sich allein gestellt.
Er muss selbst wissen,
was er gern möchte.
Ich möchte ihm nicht sagen:
"Du musst Musiker werden."
Einfach, was er will.
Ich sehe jetzt: Er hat Talent.
Man sollte einfach tun,
was einen glücklich macht.
Ca va?
Wenn er auf der Bühne steht,
ist er glücklich, finde ich.
Vielleicht Musiker,
vielleicht Fussballspieler.
* Klare, weiche
und wehmütige Melodie *
Es ist ein grosser Aufwand.
Aber das Wichtigste ist schon,
dass er den Spass an der Musik
nicht verliert.
Das ist selbst eine Riesenfreude.
* Intensive, hohe Klänge *
Wir verzichten einfach
auf teure Ferien.
Jetzt, da sie uns brauchen, ist es
uns wichtig, für sie da zu sein.
Es geht nicht nur um den Sport.
Das Drumherum ist eine Lebensschule.
Das wollen wir mitgeben.